[Music]
let's talk about the history ariana hold
up hold up hold up we can't talk about
any history without my brother here is
he
hey yo
what's up man
what's up
my partner my brother they want to talk
about the history of avianis is it okay
we come from east new york brooklyn our
parents and grandparents immigrated from
uzbekistan at that point in time it was
the ussr my father was actually a
jeweler and he opened up a wholesale
business he was doing phenomenal in the
gold and then my brother and i and we
graduated high school 98 99 we just said
to our father like listen we like what
what tito the jeweler is doing what
jacob the jeweler is doing and we want
to go on that direction because you know
those were our role models back then
and look at where we are today
we're here we're on top of the world
and we're creating the most magnificent
pieces out there
[Music]
kevin was just telling me looking for
some watches are you looking for watches
let's go to the wall of watches right
after
uncut gems happened because since 1999
when we opened up our doors here at
aviani's we've always been reaching a
lot of different people within a lot of
different industries
camron co-founder of the diplomats he
was supposed to be part of the movie
reached out so he ended up bringing adam
sandler
and the production team over they liked
what they saw here and they moved
forward in shadowing us to create their
film
adam sandler was shadowing my brother he
was always around us because i was
always on the phone talking to dealers
dealing with things and he actually was
checking out how i was talking and
moving and watch the how i use the loop
how i use the tweezers you know just to
see what an everyday diamond dealer does
i actually created all the jewelry in
the movie uh whatever adam sandler was
wearing whatever keith was wearing kevin
garnett all the stars that didn't have
jewelry i supplied the jewelry for the
film everything is is exactly to the to
the t in the movie there was a bunch of
stuff in it that was real you know
people live a life including the
kidnapping part the game people really
do get kidnapped people gamble people
gamble out here i hear stories where
people have lost tens of millions of
dollars out here on sports bettings and
and if you don't pay they're coming for
you you do good good things happen you
do bad bad things happen and that movie
showed it to you for real
lizzie thank you i'm problem joke
appreciate you too i love you man i love
you as well
now enough about all that let's just
talk about what the artwork is all about
ladies and gentlemen
the first pen that i want to touch up on
is the male mona lisa my man cam
made this face and this picture so
popular this [ __ ] is on everything i'm
saying on toilet paper
on socks on shirts on
tablecloths curtains bed sheets even all
your girls underwear
we're going to be enough taking them
starting bids is probably going to be at
20 000.
cam'ron he definitely gave us that
battery on our back his first project
that he gave us to do was that big
diplomat plate
and then it had the diplomat eagle on
there you know a bigger version than
this this is my personal piece
cam is family to me so we always
wrapping each other and i mean so we did
something like this about
15 times the size
it was a big plate
like that
with a big bird just like
that blue face is my man this particular
concept came from a wrist it was
supposed to be you know how people wear
the bandanas on their wrist and they're
flagging so i was gonna create a a
bracelet for him
rather he said to me joe you know i love
the concept can you create this into a
collar for me instead and i say yo you
know what you're a crazy man
why would you want something you know
how big this is gonna be around your
neck he said bro that's the whole point
that's the whole point
so i created him this particular collar
years ago
and this broke the internet can you
imagine
you walking in somewhere and you see
somebody sitting there with this
particular collar on what will be going
through your mind
right here's about a half a million
let's talk about
who put aviani on the map if you guys
remember jacket edge there was uh the
twins there miss casey is their mother
on the first date that we opened our
doors here miss casey walks in
she introduced herself as just a regular
person and she has two kids that she
wants to get
these je pieces made for
that was our first major celebrity
person who put us on the map
you know just to talk about our
creativity and our execution is this jet
lag piece shout out to my man stacks for
giving us the opportunity to create this
form so this is an actual jet
a fighter jet as you can see it's
two-tone we even got his bombs and stuff
on here you got pave flowers set in here
you got spaghetti's right there if you
could think it if you could dream it we
can make it for you guys
something like this will cost you around
55 000
so make sure when you um come see us get
your bag ready
the next pendant that i want to discuss
is my man black zach
you know we didn't actually make the
letters
in the piece
he had this particular piece already so
he brought it to us and said joe what
can you do with this what we did was
take the initials apart
create this plate you know that's it's
sitting on this thing is pretty heavy as
you can see i'm breathing hard it's
about a kilo kilo is about a thousand
grams in gold
so as you can see there's two locking
mechanisms
which most people don't do we created as
you can see there's no lock on the chain
what they got to do is pocket the lock
store somewhere so when they want to
wear the chain dolo without the
particular medallion they just take the
lock out take the medallion off and
connect the chain
i mean the medallion like that is about
a hundred thousand
we all know who bobby schmurder is he
kept it solid kept it a hundred and he
kept it quiet so
everything that he does it's either this
or this
so this particular pendant right here
slash collar this is a lock
that is doing this
and every other five six links you got
another emoji that's like this
so if you can't shut up this way we're
gonna take your mouse shut this way
[Music]
let's talk about two chains you know
i've been i've been working with two
chains for so long now i think it's been
what two decades now damn near so
he walks into my store
and sees
this bad boy
look at all the detail work from the
lock to the chain to the medallion to
the overall finishing of this particular
set
now this has a ring
and a bracelet to go with it i've been
doing two changes jewelry for two
decades now and all i've been doing is
elevating my game just as much as he's
elevated his game
something like this is more or less the
whole set is i would say 450 000
bracelet chain and ring
i want to make a statement when i walk
into a room so i created this
magnificent piece for myself i want you
to take a look at that with all the
emeralds the baguettes the two tone the
spike the round stones just take a look
at how this is particularly made you
know just like entertainers or athletes
they invest into their self and to their
image
walking into a room throwing this on
this [ __ ] sure makes a hell of a
statement don't it
i mean if you'd be interested in
something like this the necklace will
cost about 160 and the medallion will
cost you about 75 000.
[Music]
we do have our own eyewear division
these are prototypes these are made
for my homegirl coyler ray obviously
everything is
still
not put together properly but these are
prototypes and we're working on the
design
take a look at this
like there's nobody that's in our
industry doing this
everybody in the industry is out there
just to make a dollar
no one is innovating no one is bringing
or pushing the envelope in
creativity
let's talk about these right here ladies
and gentlemen
first one's ever done
these are the louis vuitton
billionaires
now does this speak volume for you
[Music]
do i have to say much
i think this says it all
you know when people come in here
and we sit there and start working for
them there's a process that we have to
go through in order to go on and get
this moving
you know the first process is obviously
sitting there and communicating with the
consumer and to see where their mind is
at
the second step is to sit there and to
sketch it out by hand the third step is
to create an actual graphic design
the fourth step is to confirm the design
with the client
the fifth step is to get into wax mode
the sixth step is to get into a raw
casting the seventh step is to get the
cast and clean it pre-polish it the
eighth step is to take it to my team
upstairs where we could cook it up get
the proper
diamonds the clarity the color
and the next step after that is to get a
diamond set and last but not least
once it comes down here after the
diamond setting
then we start assembling the pieces if
they are in pieces
and then we get it polished up
and make that phone call to the client
let them come in and see their
particular piece get finalized and bring
everything that they had in mind to life
clients are out there in the world doing
what they're supposed to be doing
these pieces are a representation of us
i would like to thank
gq on the rocks and the staff for coming
on in and taking this moment out to
share
the history of aviani and company and we
love you guys and appreciate you guys
[Music]